I'm this activity is aimed at least
seven students and and I would use it at
the beginning of a lesson and to just
revise and maybe you can see where the
students are at with recognizing
fractions so this activity practices
recognizing fractions in the visual
forms but it can form written form or
really important and you know and you
don't just have to use a few seven
students you can make it more difficult
to you know so yes you can adapt it and
so the rules for this activity um the
teacher will start with a card and
finish you the card right um I have
their diagram whatever that diagram
represents the student will have to say
what that fraction is now this is good
for the teacher because they can assess
where the students are at help set for
example that's a half some students
might say 12 is that correct no Celia
fix the way that they are saying or how
they say them so that's the diagram then
they'll say who has whatever they have
ridden fraction is so there's four
fifths and then the person that has four
fifths represented in a diagram a sec
all right have full physical and so on
and it will work around until it comes
back to me okay let's have a quikr um I
have a half you has four piece so now
you say hi I have four clips we have 7
theft
they don't have to fake quarters on the
diagram has 26 to pass tonight I have 7x
yeah that's pretty nice I have
I for one of the best to Kuala I have
two quarters he has 38 I have 57 soon as
56 I have five years ago aks has 40 I
have 46 who has five see what was that
feels bad night no no i don't know if
i'm not sure i was told also to use all
54 cards but so again i would get back
to you oh I have the whole thing is and
I think it'll be good for students to
say that four fourths is a whole five
feet is a whole you know and they can
see them a diagram see ya thats back to
me thank you